Now While most Republicans are trying to
crack down on China's influence in the
United States House Financial Services
chairman Patrick McKenry you know the
guy with the bow tie wants to let it
grow he's blocking a bipartisan
Amendment to the ndaa that would require
businesses to report investments in
China and other adversaries to the
government McKenry says he's doing it
because the measure would strengthen
rather than weaken the objectives of
xiin pin and the Chinese Communist Party
joining me now Robert lighthiser former
US trade rep in the Trump Administration
Bob how do you respond to his defense of
his opposition to that sensible
legislation well well I would say first
of all we have to remind ourselves and I
think Gordon did that and you do it
constantly just how big a threat this is
right I mean we're in a cold war with
China they're a very aggressive very
threatening uh uh adversary and every
time your your viewers watch the news
and watch these wars going on around the
world realiz iiz that those are proxy
wars against us and the pay Master for
both of them is China so we have to kind
of remind ourselves of that just so this
is the most serious geopolitical threat
we've probably faced as a nation so I
start with that it the argument that
that Mr McKenry has and I I should say
you know I know Mr McKenry a little bit
he's had a a great career in the in the
house he's a he's a he's a smart guy
he's he's you know he was Chief Deputy
Whip he did good things he helped us
with usmca and a lot of good things but
on this the most important geopolitical
issue he's wrong so their argument
basically is look at if you invest more
in China you do more business with China
they're going to become like Switzerland
well that is exactly the view that the
Clinton administration had ridiculous
now we have and by the way at that time
you and I both said it was nonsense that
was the reason we gave China this
favored trade relationship it was
because with this notion now we're 23
years later we've trans erred probably
10 trillion dollar to them they're more
authoritarian they're more aggressive
they're more anti-American they spy on
us more they send over as you just
showed 24,000 people just for give you a
frame of reference that's about two Army
divisions that that we know of right
that's that doesn't even count but China
Bob Bob China China is let me just say
China has all sorts of structural
problems they're dealing with real
estate uh you know collapse all sorts of
other issues why would McKenry
and why would any Republican let alone
any any elected official want to throw
them a Lifeline now Reagan didn't do
that with the Soviet
Union it's it it makes no sense at all
we should this by the way is a very
important Amendment but it's not nearly
strong enough it was it was watered down
by by the Chamber of Commerce and the
Biden Administration but it's
fundamentally important that we passed
this and I hope that Mr McKenry doesn't
realizes that that that this is going to
be a very important part of his legacy
his he's had a very fine career and now
to have this is your legacy I I just
hope he doesn't end up doing it and let
me make one other point quickly LA and
that is that while he's one guy the
leaders 400 house members would vote for
this the leadership is responsible too
they have to get this through it's not
just this one guy everybody has
responsibility this is a very popular
provision 96 votes in the Senate right
it would get 400 in the house all right
this means speaker Johnson and Mitch
McConnell we want to hear from both of
you Bob you're brilliant always great to
see you thank you